أحدث التطورات في
رد الفعل المستمر ضد تطبيق الفيديو tik-tok
amazon تعليمات لجميع
موظفيها بحذف التطبيق فورًا
من هواتفهم مشيرًا
إلى وجود مخاطر أمنية وفقًا لشخص مطلع على
الأمر ، يأتي هذا عقب ادعاءات من
إدارة ترامب بأن التطبيق يمكنه
تقويض الأمن القومي ، وفي وقت سابق من
هذا الأسبوع ، قال البيت الأبيض إنه
يفكر في حظر التطبيق تمامًا ،
مراسل CNN التكنولوجي Brian Fong معي
الآن وبريان ، ما يقوله tick-tock جيدًا
Tech Talk يدعي أنه مرتبك في
قوله إنه لا يفهم
الأسباب التي تجعل أمازون
تتخذ هذا القرار لكنها تطلب إجراء حوار
مع الشركة لمعالجة مخاوفها
الآن بالطبع ، الخوف الكبير هنا الذي
حدده الكثيرون هو احتمال
أن تنتهي بيانات Tech Talks في
أيدي الحكومة الصينية Tech
Talk بالطبع مملوك لشركة Bite Dance
وهي شركة صينية على الرغم من أن
tik-tok تقول إنها تخزن بيانات
العملاء الأمريكيين في الخدمة  rs مقرها في الولايات
المتحدة ولكن بالطبع عدد من النقاد
قلقون من أنه لا يزال من الممكن أن ينتهي
الأمر بنقل تلك البيانات
بطريقة ما إلى بكين بناءً على
قوانين الأمن القومي التي تمتلكها بكين على
الشركات الصينية مثل رقصة البايت الآن ،
يقول خبراء الأمن السيبراني إنك  تعرف على
نوع البيانات المعرضة للخطر هنا ،
فأنت تعلم أن Tech Talk تجمع أشياء مثل
عناوين IP ، موقعك ،
معرف جهاز المعرف الفريد الخاص بك x 'كل هذه
المعلومات يمكن أن تشكل خطرًا
على الأمان إذا وقعت في الأيدي الخطأ ،
على سبيل المثال إذا كنت  تعرف تكشف
عن مواقع القوات أو المعلومات
حول سلوك مسؤولي المخابرات
وكل ذلك
دفع الجيش والبحرية الأمريكية إلى حظر
tik-tok من الجيش وقد أوصى بعض
صانعي السياسة مثل السناتور جوش هاولي
الحكومة الأمريكية
حظر tik-tok من الأجهزة الحكومية
تمامًا التي قال خبراء الأمن السيبراني
إنها حالة أكثر تعقيدًا
بكثير من منتقدي tick-tocks  اجعل
الأمر يبدو بالطبع أن الكثير من
المعلومات نفسها التي يجمعها tik-tok يتم
جمعها أيضًا من قبل الشركات الأمريكية مثل
Facebook Google و Twitter
وبالطبع أنت تعلم أن المعلومات
قد تهدد توم أيضًا
للأمن القومي إذا
لم يكن kurz الصيني  قادرًا على الوصول إلى ذلك
أيضًا ، ويقول خبراء الأمن السيبراني
إنك تعلم أن هذا
يوضح في النهاية كيف يمكننا ذلك  يفتقر إلى
الخصوصية الوطنية الشاملة وحماية البيانات
لجميع الأمريكيين